[Music]
welcome aboard let's see we can pick up
today yes we're on West Street
approaching chambers in lower Manhattan
that's Stuyvesant High School right
there Hudson River to the right I call
it the moat because it's part of what
surrounds Manhattan insulating it from
like New Jersey and Brooklyn and Queens
and the Bronx Manhattan of course is an
island got millions of people on this
island who like Bridge themselves in
inject themselves in through tunnels
passageways oh this Chuck Chuck I'm a
fan of technology so a car takes me
where I need to go whoo
how you doing man are you going oh my
god how you doing I'm a clearly out of
shape is how I'm doing Wow Oh see people
running on the west side have well you
don't know like whoo feels good oh my
god I just love how every time and we
run into a lake see you I know every
time the other I get in the car it's
such a funny thing we always run into
another astrophysicist a theoretical
physicist
and this is our is our new friend Jana
and our new our new friend this is Jana
doctor Jan 11 yes yeah is a very radical
physicist and any different from
theoretically being a physicist and the
author of black hole blues yeah okay so
you pushing it now you call them sounds
you know if you were floating near the
black hole two black holes colliding
Jana the day just began you know can we
like don't you think your ear mechanism
could respond the ringing space-time
even in vacuum that you would actually
hear the gravitational waves maybe some
frequencies you're saying in the
vibration of the space-time continuum
yeah that will vibrate your eardrum the
gravitational waves are literally in the
human auditory range and there were
detectors that were originally designed
to just resonate like okay your
mechanism would right so in principle
you could actually hear it even in empty
space so I think it's very close to a
sound it's not just